at this council meeting many dimensions
of the energy union were discussed the
governance in the context of the
construction of the energy union the
internal market the energy efficiency
Commissioner kenyetta has reported on
the negotiations of the cop21 and we had
a very lively debate on that as well the
council first adopted conclusions on the
governance of of the governance system
of the energy union then still under the
same agenda item the vice-president
South kovitch presented the state of the
union energy 2015 energy efficiency has
been addressed yep dimdi aim was to
adopt a general approach on the draft
regulation on the labeling of products
with this general approach adopted the
council is now ready to continue
negotiations with the european
parliament in 2016 the Paris climate
conference is a unique opportunity to
accelerate Europe's energy transition
that was locally produced cleaner energy
and it's also a tremendous opportunity
to position European energy companies in
the list of the new global market of
low-carbon energy and energy efficient
technologies market the European
electricity market needs them to adapt
to a preform structural change moving
towards increasing centralization low
carbon technologies and an increasing
share of renewables the conclusions that
I can drove on to these discussions are
that is there is a huge market for our
European energy operators and technology
providers that the global energy
transition to clean energy is not only
underway but is unstoppable and that a
successful palace agreement will
accelerate this transition and boost
clean energy markets in Europe can amass
split in this Marcus